so how do you end up linking up with the
ybn kids because you obviously I met
nimir through you yeah corday through
you told me about chordates [__] you
were like there's this kid we're out in
Maryland here's the SoundCloud link yeah
like before the freestyle came out so
crazy bro you know what's crazy Jeff
that's a fact you're really like you
really were the first person who like
outside of like me of course like work
with him you were the first person who's
on Courtney for real because no one even
knows that the First music I heard from
corday was a SoundCloud thing bro yeah
you sent me a link and it was like it
was before any of those videos came out
it was before he was out here yeah I
just wanted to see your opinion because
you were super supportive of the ybn
[__] you you always supported us so I
wanted your opinion that's so funny
though bro you really were the first one
on them
um now I got a call from my my boy he's
OG
um James he's a lawyer and he was like
y'all I got this kid
actually it was for my boy Byron who
called me first
who was working with us on management at
the time he was a part of management
he's like yo um
me and James have this kid why be in the
mirror
and he needs you know he needs a manager
like he's about to be on the road and
he's leaving tomorrow his mom was
involved the first two right his mom was
just always around mom yeah not busy
she's just like right that's her only
child she just like couldn't let him
leave home but I was supposed to go on
like a five day road trip with them just
to go [__] off and party with Coco right
he was on tour with [__] dizzy so I
bet we're about to jump on the tour bus
and go party in Denver Salt Lake City
right Vegas and I got that call and I
didn't know who namir was bro I was
pretty much actually about to be done
with the music industry I was about to
just stay on the Brand's side of [__] in
um in corporate I was just tired of like
hustling so much bro yeah and then I got
that call
and he's like yo uh it's a it's a it's a
California leg of a tour and he needs
someone I'm like yo I'm about to I got
plans though I'm like about to just go
[__] off and he said all right well I'm
just telling you like this kid's doing a
million views a day on YouTube right now
first first ever video and whoever we
put out there is probably gonna end up
bonding with him and that's gonna be
like the solidified position right so I
was like give me five minutes hung up I
was talking to come call I'm like yeah
checked him out yeah I checked them out
and I'm like oh [__] like eight million
views and
nine days right on this video
yeah it was and if you remember a
million views for a video at the time
was still like kind of like that was
traditionally like a big record for an
artist if you had a million views on
YouTube for sure it's not like we hit
the SoundCloud wave right after if you
remember when people could do a million
views in a day but Cole Bennett kind of
changed that yeah now the YouTube [__]
was big for sure yeah before that if you
had a million views that was a big
record so for him to have like eight
million views in nine days I was like yo
I can't miss this opportunity so I met
him at the Mondrian like an hour later
it's like one in the morning found out
that we didn't have a bus driver it was
a shitty van I was gonna have to drive
it I had no license
I showed back up four hours later like
five in the morning jumped in
with like five of these like little wild
young kids namir was super cool he's
pretty quiet he didn't know what the
[__] was happening bro like this is all
happening so fast and we went on like
um six City California run who like kind
of like the shittiest towns in
California like Bakersfield
Fresno was one it was like
what what's was it not a letter no that
aletta's local it was like um Oxnard
no that's a pretty cool town to be
Modesto Stockton it was Stockton was one
of them no Modesto was one of them yeah
and then it went way up into Humble
County bro like where people don't even
go but we bought and then we came back
down into Arizona so we bonded we got
real close and the rest was kind of
History bro like you know he my mirror
moved in with me no I know he was living
with you for a while
Brad
the hype man whose name is Glizzy
and I'm here I had ybn Almighty Jay I
had our DJ
living with us bro I have like five of
these old [__] living in my life Jesus
with [__] two dogs and then I met and
bought a dog from Jazz Prince
and it was a it was a
um
Almighty Jay living with you when he was
[__] Blac Chyna
yeah I made the phone call like I called
TMZ
to pull up on him outside of the bowling
alley with China
yo I was on a plane plane was about to
take off he calls me he's like yo we're
at the bowling alley
um because he was [__] with China for
like two weeks but I'm like you know we
got to get this out bro like this is
like gold bro you [__] China like
right Jay's all skinny he's like 18. so
I'm like yo at some point you just gotta
let me know when y'all out in public and
I'm I'm gonna do what I gotta do he
calls me he's like yo I'm at the bowling
all over China I'm about to leave I was
like yo I need you to hold her there for
10 minutes I'm gonna call TMZ and have
them pull up
he's like ah yo I don't know if I can
hold her but I'm gonna try my planes
won't leave in like five minutes
so I'm like yo where are you guys at
he's like man we're going out the left
entrance out the the side that goes into
the parking lot I need you to go out the
other side the other side on the street
side this bush is there TMZ's way he
said I I I'm gonna redirecting hold on
I'm gonna call you right back
my plane took off so now I'm sitting
there in the air waiting right Wi-Fi
kicks in in like 30 minutes he texts me
he's like yo my bad he said yo they got
it they got it they all jumped out she's
pissed I'm like that's perfect they got
it though he's like yeah I was like what
did you do he was like I just act like I
didn't know what was going on I was like
what did she do he's like she just kept
on walking
she's pissed though bro I'm like yo it
don't matter we got it yo the next day
so I'm flying cross country right
New York off a red eye
so it's like 6 a.m but it's like 3 A.M
in L.A
yo like I take a nap in New York because
I'm jet like I wake up like 9 A.M it's
already everywhere on the like all over
the [__] media about like six seven
a.m it was [__] everywhere that's
such a weird situation I didn't have a
problem like a child for real I wasn't
he 18. yeah it was 18. oh my God he was
18. yo Jay was knocking him down but I'm
not gonna lie down Jay hit everything
bro Jay's hit more
yo Jace hit every bad [__]
in in Black
in brown American hip-hop culture bro
Jay's here tomorrow bro
interesting Jay's hit them all you have
yeah
almost any Chick you can think of who's
popping right now
in the female landscape a rat
Almighty Jay's been there Almighty Jay
Almighty Jay's a man what a list he's
the one I can't wait to talk to him and
he's still on a run but now it's just
like it's way more Under Wraps because
he's under wraps